I'm starting out big broad here for your
producing process what is something that
has stayed the same from following to
now but then on the other hand what is
something that has changed based on the
way the industry film making technology
and maybe even audience viewing habits
have
evolved do you know what I think that
we've pretty much stayed the same I mean
it's interesting you know we have a like
every film is different
which is what I love about the job like
no year is the same from you know one
year to another no day is the same one
day to another um and every movie that
we make we've leared something about
what we should do what we shouldn't do
um and we've evolved our process over
time um but ultimately at its core is
kind of the same you know
[Music]
um
and you know
it's interesting I feel like although we
make pretty large scale films I think
that most people would agree that they
who work on
them they they feel like smaller movies
like we keep it pretty small the the the
sort of core group we don't have video
Village we you know the actors are
mostly on set the whole time it kind of
feels a little bit Indy even though
we're also doing crazy special effects
and and things like that um but then in
terms of the sort of the broader
industry question I actually feel that
we've managed to we've been very lucky
um that our films have been as
successful as they have because we've
been able to kind of stick to our guns
in terms of what we believe stay the
same we don't we don't get these like
classically like beautiful Blockbuster
films like you you two are kind of
leading the charge with that right now
yeah we've we've been incredibly lucky
because um be you know if the films had
not been as successful I don't think we
would have been able to to sort of
dictate our terms in that way um and one
of the things that I'm really pleased
about with with oppenheimer's success is
that you know we've been hearing from
the business that theatrical is over
nobody wants to you know kids don't have
attention spans they're not going to go
to the theater you know all of that all
nonsense and opom has proved you know
this summer has proved that that's not
the case at all people are absolutely
just as interested in theaters in seeing
movies in theaters as they always have
been we just have to make the the the
movies that they want to see there you
go that's the key isn't it so you
brought up uh that this production yeah
it's a big budget movie but it's got a
more intimate feel to it is there
anything that you see a lot of big
budget maybe franchise movies doing in
terms of overspending where you would
say you know if you pair it down and
have less it's actually going to wind up
being more in the finished product well
I don't know CU I haven't worked on
those films but so I don't know exactly
how they do it but I will say that when
we sort of map out how we're going to
make the film what we're trying to do is
make sure that every dollar we spend is
on the screen
so you know and also we set ourselves
like you
know sometimes the parameters that you
are set or set for yourselves in terms
of the way you're going to shoot the
film sort of leads to a certain magic
when people have to sort of sit down and
say okay well we don't have X but maybe
we can do it in a different way and then
we'll come up with why and I think that
sometimes that's where true Innovation
happens is when you're not just
following the you know the sort of usual
way of doing things just because that's
the way it's done you are having to be
inventive and and and that leads to
Magic like making a movie this big on a
57 Day shooting schedule when I heard
that I'm like no way it was crazy way
for another production out there that
might be sitting there thinking like I
want more days I want more time why
would you recommend a tighter schedule
to get such a big movie done I think
that the nice thing about making this
film in 57 days was that the energy
stayed High the whole way through you
know I mean we've done movies that that
you know we had sort of 128 day
schedules on it gets really old it gets
you know people get really tired you
know the nice thing about a fast
schedule is that it keeps it fresh
everyone was excited to be there and you
know I but I I also wouldn't recommend a
57 Day schedule unless you really have a
plan for how you're going to do it and
we were very lucky that you know we had
worked with Hoy our DP before and when
Chris went to him and said look do you
think we could do this HOA was really
thought hard and then he sort of
adjusted his you know working
methodology in order to make it work you
know we only had sort of One camera we
didn't have you know he did much of it
handheld which is crazy by the way when
you're talking about an IMX camera um so
so yeah I mean I you know that was great
and we also we we we don't you know our
actors don't spend much of their time in
their trailers because we don't give
them big trailers we give them crappy
little trailers and so they tend to then
want to be on because there's no reason
to be back at base camp and that also
lends itself to a fast shoot I love that
quality so so much another broader
question going into filming which scene
did you think would be most challenging
to pull off and then ultimately was that
indeed the case or did a different scene
wind up catching you all by surprise oh
I mean
gosh um things you never see the one
that's going to get you ever and I've
made enough films at this point that I
know that um I think that the the scene
that um I thought was going to be the
hardest probably was the Trinity test I
was really nervous about how that was
going to be because we were shooting it
out in the desert in the in this vast
area and you know nights never fun um
but you know because we all were so
focused
on the difficulties of that I think you
know it seemed it went it went very well
um you know there were really no scenes
that were bad though on this side like
everything went so great we got so lucky
we not lucky that's what happens when
you're well planned and you surround
yourself with the right people who are
there for the right reasons well and who
are also sort of willing to shift if
they have to like you know you can't be
so locked in on doing things a certain
way
because life will serve you up a whole
different scenario and then you have to
throw it all up in the air and and do
something different and that and I think
that that's the key to sort of
successful film making is sort of having
a plan for every scenario but also being
willing to improvise on the day if you
have to so we've been talking a lot
about the big of this movie but I know
that you and Chris are also very detail
oriented can you pinpoint a tiny detail
in this movie that isn't spoken about or
front and center in frame that you knew
you had to include and it was important
but we don't necessarily feel it but we
could feel it informing the movie and
kind of building atmosphere I mean for
me I think it's there are many many
performance aspects actually um that fit
that bill um you know the film we knew
we had to make it it couldn't be longer
than 3 hours because we wanted to put
the film out on IM I I have a feeling a
lot of people out there are sitting
there thinking like three hours sounded
long but like now I could have watched
more well this is the thing you know
three yes three hours is long and I did
not I wasn't very happy about that when
I first read the script let me tell you
but you know we knew that we that was we
knew that it had to be through hours
because of the IMAX platter we couldn't
go any longer or it wouldn't have fit
and so I think the first time we watched
the film it was probably about three and
a half hours and from that point on they
just had to pull stuff out they didn't
cut whole scenes they just Tri trimmed
and trimmed and trimmed um and I think
that when we got to around three hours
I'm sure that we could have gone further
I'm sure that Chris and Jen could have
cut probably another five or 10 minutes
out but I'm really glad that they didn't
because I think that there are I'm not
going to call out any specific ones um
but I but there are so many sort of tiny
performance details like looks like
Downey does some amazing looks in
particularly in that last um sequence
where you can just see everything that's
going on in his head the sort of um yeah
it's just incredible and I think any any
any Titan we would have lost those deps
where he gives like the slightest smirk
and I'm like oh my God that one frame of
material says so much and I love it
congratulations congratulations all good
coming your way you guys deserve thank
you it was really nice to meet
you